are you in greece no  because i know this went on with the  brady bunch completely false  there's another one of those out there  where people just assume you were in  everything  [Laughter]  that woman has been around she isn't i'm  like where's waldo  prepared for many episodes of ladies  night where i've like  dug deep and this is the first time i've  seen as much of that  never i was not in greece and i was  never a child actor the little girl in  the brady bunch  i wouldn't even look like that when i  was a little girl but you could believe  little girl was me my daughters tell me  about this stuff and sometimes they  they send it to me but i don't i think  it's a rabbit hole i just want to keep  moving forward and doing things and  and not you know get caught up  you